schauen wir auf die steigenden
energiepreise denn die treffen uns alle
und sie haben auch heftige konsequenzen
für den amateursport zum beispiel dort
fürchtet man harte einschnitte und
betroffen sind dann auch wieder die ganz
kleinen das gas wird knapp die
energiepreise explodieren längst wird
über einsparungen gesprochen diese
horrormeldungen sorgen nicht nur bei
verbrauchern für schrecken auch in den
fußballverein geht jetzt die angst um
besonders betroffen der amateurbereich
er muss mit wenig geld auskommen lebt
vom ehrenamt und kann sich massiv
steigende energiepreise schlicht nicht
leisten
kostentreiber nummer eins die
flutlichter hermann winkler vom
deutschen fußball bund macht sich große
sorgen na das ist so damoklesschwert
können wir das flutlicht betreiben wir
als verband und deshalb wäre es schlimm
wenn die vereine gezwungen werden teures
flutlicht an zu machen um die spieltage
zu schaffen aber die energiepreise
explodieren so doll dass wir im prinzip
damit die vereine in die insolvenz
treiben das könnten wir als verband auch
nicht verantworten insofern braucht wird
eine lösung dunkelheit kein flutlicht
bedeutet kein training und keine spiele
abends und in den wintermonaten und zwar
auch für die kleinsten unsere kinder
müssen sie nach den harten corona jahren
erneut auf training auf die für sie so
wichtige bewegungen verzichten brot nach
dem krone lockdown nun der flutlicht
lockdown der jugend und kinder sport
steht erneut vor einer zerreißprobe um
das zu verhindern hat hermann winkler
klare forderungen an die politik wer
spürt vor einer unterstützung der
ehrenamtlich geführten vereine der
amateurvereine wer so wie es bei den
arbeitnehmern einen zuschlag gibt von
300 euro sind glaube als energiekosten
pauschale dies auch den vereinen zu
gewähren und damit hilfe zu geben direkt
die etwas nützt das gas wird knapp die
lichter drohen auszugehen die politik
muss reagieren damit unsere kleinsten
nicht wieder das ausbaden müssen was die
großen verbockt haben
und wir sprechen darüber mit dem
sportpolitiker und obmann im
sportausschuss dem abgeordneten philipp
krämer von den grünen hallo herr krämer
direkt die frage eingehen dürfen
flutlicht abgeschaltet werden um energie
zu sparen selbst wenn jugend
sportvereine ab herbst dann nicht mehr
trainieren können
merkel und ich glaube wir müssen
versuchen da eben eine realistische
linie zu fallen die bedeutet natürlich
an den zehn tagen r weniger gas oder gar
kein gas aus russland haben braucht man
eine priorisierung der verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher
und dazu gehören sicherlich irgendwann
auch sportanlagen jetzt ist es aber so
dass wir insbesondere kinder und
jugendliche in den letzten zwei jahren
durch die korona pandemie massiv unter
druck gesetzt haben dass dort oftmals
kein sport stattfinden konnte und
dementsprechend ist klar meiner
einschätzung beziehungsweise meine
meinung dass die in der priorisierung
ganz oben stehen müssen und wir uns erst
mal anschauen müssen welche alternativen
wir haben gas einzusparen so ist es so
sehe ich es auch ist es denn auch
wirklich so elementar dieses flutlicht
was du würde man überhaupt damit
einsparen müssen sie das
ja das ist durchaus eine große belastung
für die vereine aber auch da gibt es
beispielsweise graubereich also auch
jetzt jeder jeder ecke oder so
ausgeleuchtet sein muss auf dem
fußballplatz das würde ich tatsächlich
mal in frage stellen aber auf der
anderen seite ist natürlich im winter in
tiefen insbesondere nach 17 uhr ist
nicht mehr möglich sport im freien zu
sein ohne diese beleuchtung und das
macht dann schon sehr große einschnitte
aus dass sind ja vier bis fünf stunden
die da diese plätze nicht mehr genutzt
werden können und das ist eine massive
belastung für den breitensport und dann
würde es sicherlich auch wieder den
aufschrei geben und das würde heißen
warum wird das eigentlich immer alles
auf dem rücken der kinder ausgetragen
wie sieht das eigentlich bei den
profisportlern aus ich meine die
trainieren ja nun mal auch im dunkeln
dann im freien
das ist so und auch hier da muss man
wahrscheinlich auch mal mit den
verbänden ins gespräch gehen gibt es ja
durchaus die möglichkeit unter anderem
die lumen zahlen die dann jeweils in den
verschiedenen bereichen auf dem platz
vor herrschen müssen eben zu reduzieren
und zu sagen ob man oder zumindest zu
prüfen ob man vielleicht auch mit einer
geringeren energie anzahl der energie
höhe zurecht kommt und die ausrichtung
eben etwas zurücknimmt das werde
möglichkeiten aber meine priorität ist
erst mal der amateur breitensportler
klaus der große herausforderung haben
wir aus den letzten zwei jahren
entstanden sind und der profisport hat
dort glaube ich ganz andere
möglichkeiten da kann man beispielsweise
mal bei rasenheizung sprecher wir haben
ja durch die weltmeisterschaft in katar
jetzt und so eine längere winterpause
möglicherweise bietet es sich an die
noch mal etwas zu verlängern wenn es
denn wirklich hart auf hart kommt und da
gibt es glaube ich andere möglichkeiten
die wirkliche effektiver werden ich
denke es wird hart auf hart kommen die
krise ist nicht mehr zu vermeiden was
sind denn ihre spar tipps
die spar tipps wie gesagt im bereich
profisport wer so etwas wie die
rasenheizung man kann sicherlich auch in
den schwimmbädern sich gedanken machen
ob man dort eben die temperatur senkt
aber auch aus eigener erfahrung
insbesondere beim babyschwimmen ist das
halt etwas was dann auch nicht wirklich
effektiv ist weil dann dort eben auch
die wasser vielleicht nicht mehr genutzt
werden kann und daher würde ich
tatsächlich eher in anderen bereichen
wir uns anschauen wie beispielsweise die
forderung in büros eine gewisse
obergrenze einzufinden dauert dass man
das durchaus machen könnte es später
nicht bei 16 grad aber 19 grad ist eine
temperatur die man aus mit mit einem
dickeren pullover dann auch umsetzen
kann und wir müssen als politik ehrlich
sein und das ist auch unsere
herausforderung dass es eben nicht
einfach sein wird diesen winter und dass
wir gemeinsam als gesellschaft
zusammenhalten sollten und eben aber
alle bereiche insbesondere auch kinder
und jugendliche mit einbeziehen sollten
uns eben nicht über gebühr belasten
dürfen es dank philipp krämer von den
grünen